all right you know I really I kind of
don't want to do this but with Alex
Stein here I think it'll be fun America
is using recovered UFOs to make
high-tech weapons intelligence officer
turned whistleblower claims U.S
recovered ET craft and opened Pandora's
Box in bombshell BBC interview I don't
believe it I think he's full of it uh
I'm gonna say this right now
as a statement of fact
this guy is lying about having any of
this information you know why
because he cannot prove anything he says
is true period And I would love for him
to to release hard evidence of this but
until then it's not really a statement
of fact because it's just me saying like
I don't believe him but what I'm trying
to get at is if dude were to sue me for
defamation for me calling him a liar
which he can't
show me the evidence prove it prove it
prove it
but um considering the levels of
distractions that we're dealing with we
got aliens we got world war three and we
got Obama's gay you know what I mean
it's like they're they're pulling out
all the stops and Desperation Century
overload did he follow you into the
bathroom yeah he did he helped me go so
uh I'm glad you're here Alexis we want
to talk about these aliens I heard
everything about the aliens I'm very
familiar with it and uh I would tell so
you've met them well I'm I am one
they're inhabiting me right now no if
they tell you that aliens are real then
they're fake if this guy that's all
right that's I believe the opposite of
work we all thought aliens were real
until they came down and claimed that's
all they had to do is the government
tells you the aliens are real I'm like
all right this is fake oh we're all
we're all let down well and I mean we
talk about what they have uh secret
technology there is something kind of
weird that because we can go to how did
they build the pyramids like how did
they do stuff that we can't do today
there is some sort of I think we're
getting Dumber I agree with but like
when I say not to is people think that
because we don't know how they did it
aliens it's like come on acoustic
levitation I think that yeah for sure
like yeah they had a bunch of horns so
one of the theories is that they would
take the giant stones and they would
have like 10 guys with horns that get
really really big and they would go and
then it would create vibrations that you
could just push the block well you've
seen that where like somebody has a real
big subwoofer system in the car and just
the sound of it it's not just for the
pressure they think it's from the sound
waves actually that can bend metal I
mean the car is like bending and the
metal will come back to its uh haven't
you ever seen those little football
games where it's got the little football
players on it turn it on it vibrates and
they start floating around they're
floating around like that's that's
that's that's one idea but uh there's a
bunch of stuff like that like uh I think
in in Rome they had concrete That Could
set underwater it's like a baby yes and
they I don't think as far as I know they
haven't been able to replicate the stuff
it's there still yeah that's wild and
then uh what is it they show like um the
roads in Rome and then you see like a
Road in Dallas
you know Dallas is just potholes
everywhere but their Road in Rome is you
know still cobblestones Roman concrete
is legit it's actually something I like
just look up in my free time but it
actually gets stronger as time goes on
so it gets denser oh and what about what
about you understand how they make it
why don't we just what about that uh
wasn't there like a Hellfire weapon they
had back in the day you know I'm talking
about there's like an ancient story
where these dudes are on a boat and then
they fired like Napalm or something that
Greek Fire Greek Fire yeah
I don't know what it is it was was it
green or is that that's Game of Thrones
it's green and it's a incendiary weapon
used by the Eastern Roman Empire the
byzantines developed in 672 A.D what was
it napalm
I don't know Greek fire that little
picture is pretty funny combustible
compound yeah this is how this is how
you ignited with the contact on water
look at this it looks like a cran
drawing maybe magnesium if it explodes
when it comes into contact with water
have you guys seen the new John Wick
there's a scene where he gets a shotgun
loaded with dragon's breath which is
magnesium fragment shotgun shells so
when you when it shoots it class lame
like not a flame but like a big it's
like metal metal flaming metal shards
yeah yeah maybe maybe they maybe they
pulverize magnesium and then fight out
of a cannon
I want to know what it's made of uh
combinations of pine resin napatha well
alchemy's real we all agree that Alchemy
is real so I mean maybe they were able
to mix Alchemy well I mean what is it
what is like mixing uh no they thought
they could turn lead to Gold yeah but in
reality I think you could turn Platinum
to Gold you can turn some stuff they're
right next to each other on the Periodic
Chart it's one proton more so if you
confuse a proton with Platinum you
should turn up with gold what would you
get the proton from
hydrogen
or helium maybe you need to diffuse a
heavy hydrogen yeah if you could use
heavy hydrogen like deuterium
um deuterium oxide which is like H I
think there's an added Neutron it's a
water molecule with an added Neutron I
think that'd be pretty cool we start
making gold out of plastic I think
that's what's happening in the sun is
it's fusing Platinum into gold well
that's why so many people are sailing
catalytic converters because there's a
little bit of platinum in the filter
Palladium for sure there's a lot of
Palladium in the catalytic converter I
think I don't know if there's Platinum I
think there's a small amount of platinum
I think maybe this LK 99 thing is
another distraction too dude I think
it's real look at that I said I said it
was a slab yeah I'm still like that all
of them but like for real
all of these crazy stories drop at the
same time that Hunter Biden is about to
go to jail and Joe Biden's being caught
up in all this and I'm just like dude
everything right now is a sign up all of
it I've missed directions
except lk99 no one's talking about it in
the media the mainstream crap yeah I got
the verse right here I was dancing it
all over my feed for like an entire day
this week like Wednesday or something
did they MSNBC it like is there any of
that because that's all the political uh
subterfuge channels where they're trying
to get you to look away I haven't
figured it out
if we just keep talking about Hunter
Biden being crooked they'll have to keep
releasing top secrets yeah they're
milking it that's right that's right
earlier today is that people are
actually trying to cause more chaos so
that the Rapture hasn't happened sooner
I kind of like that conspiracy that's
dangerous so that's one of the one of
the conspiracy theories is that the
powerful Global Elites want to force the
second coming of Jesus so they're making
prophecy happen dear Lord yeah if I was
George Soros I would be doing that he
didn't have much time left I mean the
reason I think LK 99 is real is because
it was developed by some Chinese dude
and he basically just showed the world
but then I don't know would the CCP
allow a Chinese guy to to tell the world
about a room temperature superconductor
what about all the people that have
built the cars that run on water have
you guys seen that yeah those are
Stanley Meyer is one of the guys here's
the problem it takes more energy to
perform the electrolysis on the water
than the than the fuel produced from the
water is is worth right is that true I
don't know so electrolysis splits the
the hydrogen oxygen and then you can use
the hydrogen as a fuel but the problem
is it takes more energy to perform the
electrolysis than you get back from the
hygienistic that's kind of like how they
use solar power and windmill so I think
a windmill has to spin every day for
five years for it to even get back its
value and what it would cost so so you
can make a car run on water but you're
just losing energy
so just have the battery directly spin
the wheel why why convert yeah water
Stanley Myers water car he said he could
run it with water instead of gasoline
but then in 1996 an Ohio court found it
to be a fraudulent claim and then the
guy was died shortly he died two years
later why why is that the final line to
everything and then the guy died shortly
later
how did he die because I remember
hearing that and I thought it was very
weird how Stanley Meyer just abruptly
well and then there was it also saw
himself out there was like a black
security guard who died under mysterious
circumstances recently and he had a Ford
Expedition that ran on water and they
say that that he yeah
this is crazy he went to a Cracker
Barrel and I think he was there to uh
with a business meeting with his brother
two potential foreign investors and he
just got up and started vomiting ran out
and said he was poisoned and then the
the official claim is that he died from
a cerebral aneurysm wait who is it
Stanley Meyer the guy who built the
water fuel car wow Cracker Barrel's
delicious so they they would never kill
it they would never oh they have the
most delicious biscuits catfish you go
to Cracker Barrel and you get the
catfish it's where you think you're safe
the chicken fried steak's good I mean
the Cracker Barrel is once they got the
knickknack section yes
where people like sneak their stage
photos that they're like on a farm into
Cracker Barrel really make it a home
everyone's looking at the wef they got
the wrong idea it's been Cracker Barrel
the whole time yeah always has always
has been it always has been Cracker
Barrel if anyone in the chat knows more
about the water car please like if
there's any value to that because I mean
what you're saying makes sense that you
need to perform the electrolysis but
then once you get the chain reaction
wouldn't that that hydrogen heat give
you enough electricity to continue the
reaction
I don't know if that's true I don't know
but you know what we should do because
we got the Super Chat from Michael
Beacon he gave me an idea I think we
should just get like a hollow like a
projector and then do one of those
hologram things they do with like you
can Project Blue beam you can protect it
you project you put a project on the
smoke and it can make it look 3D or onto
like a glass panel and then we just have
like aliens land in New York and then
when everyone's watching the aliens just
say like we want you all to trust your
government we have that Tim we have that
have you never heard of Project Blue
game no no no I'm saying we gotta have
aliens Line in New York and then
everyone's like what what's the message
what have what have you come to teach us
okay right I'm gonna say it trust Joe
Biden vote for him in 2024 and everybody
should be gay I think that's what
they're gonna do future is Trends what's
project bluebeam
so it's technology developed by NASA
this has all been Declassified where
they can actually make it look like
Jesus is coming back from the Rapture
they can make anything look like yo you
can't search for a blue beam right now
no look at this yeah I looked it up and
heavily redacted but uh no Project Blue
beam is real and it's basically whether
it's I don't know if it's hologram I
don't know how it works but they can
project an image in the sky and they say
that one of the applications would be to
fake the Resurrection talking plasma Ian
talks about it all the time so maybe
that talking plasma is part of it where
they take triangulated lasers into a
point in the atmosphere and that creates
a ball of plasma that they'll move
around like a laser pointer if you have
if yeah you have three lasers
when they when you fire the laser you
can't see the beam you can see the point
but if all three lasers intersect you'll
be able to see a ball in the sky and
then all three lasers can move so it
makes it look like something's flying
around the speed of light and
theoretically if you've got 9000 lasers
coordinating you could create like the
image of a dragon and move that around
yeah yep that's that's not even that
complicated kids in high school do this
you ever see those uh those those shows
where the guy will be like dancing and
then he'll grab a laser beam and he'll
spin it like a like he's not really
spinning it he's just putting his hand
where the laser is and then they've
choreographed how to move to make it
look like the laser is actually in his
hands yeah but he's actually just
pretending to grab it sometimes they
mess up you can see them it's they're
cool shows thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time